This is the payroll recording for November 17th, 2025 to November 23rd, 2025.
Monday AM shift. John Neal was the only server slash bartender.
So there's no tip out. The final tip number for John Neal from Monday AM is $120.20.
Austin Kelly was the sole bartender slash server for the PM shift.
So the AM was just broke. The PM is Austin Kelly was the only server slash bartender.
These are the before tip out numbers because he did have a utility guy.
So before tip out, Austin Kelly $162.69.
Then we need to do the calculation to tip out Maddox $16.46.
Keep in mind that this is all that if I'm saying just first names, for example, Maddox is Maddox Porter.
Austin is Austin Kelly. Janelle is Janelle Backe. Mark is Mark Baryanek.
Coban is Coban Cross. Ryan is Ryan Alexander. Kevin Warley. Austin is Austin Kelly.
So on to Tuesday, November 18th, 2025. This is the AM shift. John Neal was solo for this shift with no support staff.
So these are the final numbers. John Neal needs to make $97.43.
Tuesday PM shift. These are the final numbers. Mike Walton and John Neal were the servers.
They need to make $133.43 each after tipping out Coban $35.32.
On to Wednesday, November 19th, 2025. It was John Neal solo, no support staff.
So these are the final tip numbers. $48.88 to John Neal.
Now on to the Wednesday PM shift. These are the final numbers. Kevin and Mike.
Again, Mike is Mike Walton. Kevin and Mike need to each make $84.47 after tip out.
And the tip out to Coban Cross needs to be $29.70. Again, it's $29.70 to Coban Cross.
On to Thursday, November 20th, 2025. The AM shift. It was just Kevin with no support staff.
So the final tip numbers are $93.29. Thursday PM shift. These are the before tip out numbers.
So we need to do the whole calculation here. Austin Kelly and Heather Martin were tip pooling.
So I'll give you Heather's numbers first. Then I'll give you Austin's numbers.
Then we need to figure out exactly what the tip out would be.
Heather Martin before tip out $124.60. Her total tip out was $16.66.
Austin Kelly before tip out $260.41. His tip out needs to be $31.34. And they need to tip out Maddox Porter.
Friday, November 21st, 2025. This is the AM shift. It was just Austin Kelly with no support staff.
So the final tip numbers are $178.83. Okay, the Friday PM shift. These are the final numbers.
Kevin and Austin each need to make $230.17. After tipping out Ryan, $65.17. Again, that's Ryan Alexander. He's a new employee.
Now on to Saturday, November 22nd, 2025. It was Austin Kelly and Mark Berianek.
And Ryan was the support staff guy, so the utility guy. So we need to do this whole calculation.
These are just straight from their reports. So this is before tip out because again we need to do the calculation.
Austin Kelly $133.77. His tip out is $11.94. Mark Berianek, his total tips and fees before tip out $142.14.
And his tip out is $29.35. Again, that needs to go to Ryan Alexander.
Okay, the Saturday PM shift. These are the final numbers. Kevin and Mark each need to make $219.68. After tipping out Ryan Alexander, $75.04.
On to Sunday, November 23rd, 2025. This is the AM shift. And these are the final numbers. Mike and Kevin each need to make $209.98.
After tipping out Ryan Alexander, $76.96.
Sunday, November 23rd, 2025. PM shift. Janelle $361.00. Austin Kelly $361.00. Kevin $361.00. Ryan Alexander $100.00.
And here are the cook's tips. Slade Walker $17.18. Tori Wells $1.08. Warren Lewis $22.14.